my name is Tatiana McDonald I was the
set decorator on Tinker Tailor Soldier
Spy and three things you need to do my
job are you have to have a good eye you
have to have a good sense of period you
have to be in tune with your designer I
think that's that's three things I went
to art school and very quickly realized
that I couldn't that I couldn't work
without a brief that I did I wasn't an
artist I wasn't gonna be painting things
there was no vast urge to create and
that and and I like parameters I like to
be told we're doing this period this is
the script these are the characters this
is the color palette and this is these
are the images we've been looking at
this is what we're after and then it's
wonderful because you know what you're
doing and you go off and you just do it
to your best ability
I am responsible for choosing everything
that is not physically built so that's
every chair every paperclip every rug
every picture every bit of fabric you
know transfer transforming the locations
or the set into something that you that
someone would believe is habitable that
that existed and then then then there's
character so you have to interpret what
the what the character in the script
what you know what whether all of that
the sort of density in the detail so
that's my job now and then I work
alongside an art director who does all
the structural stuff that builds the
sets textures finishes all of that sort
of stuff set decoration is nebulous it
is it's basically understanding what
people need of you having a good eye
being creative being able to bring
something to it being able to interpret
the script I can draw but it's not
necessary actually for my job just being
very very very thorough when I work for
example on Tinker Tailor you you you get
home and although there's nothing
physically you can do your head is
is-is-is
I'll sleep and at one point I would come
across a problem in mind in my sleep and
it would wake you up you would register
the problem you go back to sleep and in
the morning you'd have three new
problems you know literally it's it's
all in your head
so it's it's it's lists and lists and
lists of stuff and do I have that and is
that going to be good enough and do I
need an alternative one of those will
that work is it going to come together
because you don't you it's all tiny bits
it's it's isolated objects that you're
finding and you're logging and you're
listing and you're ordering and at some
point they will just all get on a truck
they'll come to you on various trucks
they'll come to one place they'll all go
in and they've got to work you haven't
got time to think
oh god no we needed a pink so for all
you need to know it's going to come
together it's got to come together and
so that all these disparate bits have to
come together it's got to work
and then
and then it's shot and then it's gone
and on tinker they were about three sets
a day
Thomas wanted the the circus he was
already talking about it to be a sort of
doughnut thing where you had a out you
had some kind of structure inside and
another an established ordinary-looking
building so you get this kind of scary
block in the middle of this Victorian
surround so you can't see it from the
street nobody knows it's there and then
they'll you get all those amazing scenes
where they're looking down from from the
from the rooftops so it was Thomas that
had that original that was his his plan
and then they found the location and it
was Maria and the CGI people that did
have brought drawing and the CGI people
that managed to create that central
reality and that's why sometimes it it
it could be if you didn't follow the
joke I mean my husband was going I don't
get the jog refer you don't get the
geography it I explained it to him and
then when he saw it a second time he got
it but you know sometimes they were
walking down staircases with glazed
tiles and it's very Edwardian and then
and then and then sometimes it's very
brutal and you've got this vast hangars
where they where they built the pods for
that for the the layers of of the circus
of the central brutalist piece it's very
intuitive it's not something that you
you can either do it or you can't you
know and time obviously the experience
helps but you know that because you know
that you've got a color palette you'll
you know you know that if if it's within
that color palette or it's going to work
because you've established that but you
don't go out looking for a green sofa
you it's it's very organic you say that
would be good and then those three
choices will dictate the next six
choices and so on so it's it's it's it's
artistic in that sense you don't go out
to find exactly what's in your mind's
eye or in your designer's mind's eye
being nominated for BAFTA is is
fantastic it's actually less so within
the industry but more just for people
it's very lovely but just in life in
general you know it's very nice for
people to go oh I saw your name on the
credits of that really good film and
you're like yes I'm not just a mother of
three you know that
that's how that's that's nice for me I
mean eventually doe-eyed managed to get
to this this point where you managed to
do work and have children and work and
you know straddle this this this thing
and so for me it's just great to get
some recognition for for something that
you know isn't slopping food into
people's mouths or changing nappies you
know that that's great
you